I mean certainly this is not a position
you feel that it's a dead though it
looks like it should be lost and it
might be a drawback miracle and seeing
that this should be a technical draw
yeah I mean F3 just keeping the pawns
intact I don't see any winning plan for
black there and just kind of walking
back with the white king if necessary
black has no past pawns after all white
has Perfect Harmony already and we do
see a handshake between Magnus Carson
and
foreign
dwindled at least four go cash and
Magnus defended The Rook end game very
confidently uh we will see yeah the
final position was just completely
locked up and
nice touch here the players discussing
the game afterwards Magnus oh
he got through a really hairy position
there uh he was in big big trouble but
ultimately defending extremely well
yeah
the future for sure but also uh
mental strengths yeah fighting pushing
Magnus all the way to here to the limits